what is that the absolute top of your
education reform was life I could do one
thing it would be to change school
funding system so that money is in
children's backpacks and it travels with
those kids to a school that they choose
what would what would that do how would
that fix things well we already know
what it would do Nick because there's so
many schools out there school choice
schools that have just absolutely been
beating the odds whether there are small
private schools or their public charter
schools online schools home schools when
parents get to select the schools for
themselves they're selecting school
organizations that are run by people who
want to be there they want to be doing
the work they're passionate what are the
biggest obstacles to really broadening
the scope of school choice a tradition
that somehow we've allowed which should
be obvious to become taboo right getting
up in the morning and deciding i'm going
to choose this restaurant i'm going to
choose this health care this doctor was
a huge deal in the health care debate
can we choose our own doctors i SAT
screaming at the television saying of
course and you should choose your own
schools was the TV on it wasn't no